welcome back everybody if you're in the
process of moving or need some
extra storage space we might have found
an affordable way
to do it one unit at a time check it out
our storage units are quite a bit
different than our competitors in that
they're all stainless steel steel and
hardwood floor constructed they have the
highest capacity
in the industry they also have hard
rubber feet to protect
people's property when they're set down
gently
aside from that they have an e-track
system built into it to secure
the contents and then they'll be able to
leave it here knowing that it's in a
secured facility
monitored 24 7 as well as climate
controlled and they won't have to worry
that's one less thing that they'll have
to worry about
we're locally owned and operated what
i'd like to have as far as an impact
both personally and professionally is
professionally i'd like to help people
in their time of need and one of the
most stressful things that people do
is move and we can help alleviate that
stress by putting in one of our
mobile storage units and then storing it
here and it's one less thing that they
have to concern
themselves with as well as personally
i'm in involved with a couple of
different charities here especially
local law enforcement as well as our
veterans
i'd like to give back to the community
to those because they have
impacted me personally over the years
and i'd like to help out
in that there's three options that
people have one one of which is a lot of
contractors use this
and even some people are doing their own
home renovations what they do is they
bring a unit to their location
we place it wherever they like i
actually use a robotic remote
device that takes it off of our truck in
an always level fashion so
it's never jostling their contents it's
always gently
setting it on the pavement and then we
roll it right up to where they need it
then they can store their contents on
site
and then when they're done with it and
they can move their contents back into
their house
then we come back and take it back to
our facility empty
the second option which is probably the
most used is what's called a curb to
curb move or
people are moving from point a to point
b we deliver the unit to point a
they fill up all their contents in the
unit they secure it we come pick it up
and then we move it to b they unload it
and then when they're done
unloading it we bring it back to our
facility and the third one that you see
behind you are the people who choose to
instead of doing the point a to point b
directly
they bring it to our facility because
they might not know where they're living
here
you know in the near future so they just
want to store it here and then when they
do
acquire a place to live then we deliver
it to that location
nice safe and sound and then they unload
it and then we come pick it up at their
convenience
the best way to contact units is either
our phone
number or they can contact us at our
website and we're also on
many social platforms as well so any of
those will work great give units
moving and portable storage a call at
that phone number 702-707-4040